foreign
game mechanics can help Foster
repetitive play which makes the game
more interesting technically it
challenges players to develop their
skills when competing with others
especially on fighting games
in Tekken the mechanics continue to
evolve or change which makes it one of
the best fighting games ever to be made
[Music]
come on
welcome to another Ocho TV special and
these are the mechanics that built the
Tekken franchise
[Music]
he's right
ready
[Music]
oh yeah
okay okay
foreign
[Music]
two okay
foreign
[Music]
okay
good evening
come on
thank you
[Music]
go go
away
[Music]
three two
three
we miss something
make sure to leave your comments below
and don't forget to like And subscribe
for more Tech and content going
somewhere
[Music]
thank you